[音楽]
を
[拍手]
今日は普段映像で約てをしていて
子テーマで考えているこの
宇宙ライジング the invisible あ
目に見えないものを可視化する
そういうことをテーマにもか考えているんですけどこのことをちょっと話していこうと
思っています
そもそもこの目に見えない物って聞いて皆さん何を思い浮かべますか
ちょっと聞いてみてもいいですかまたか
はいっ
なるほどつまり目に見えないものというのは真実だとそういう神様
なるほど上さん深いです
なかなか無かっ
なかなか難しい遠くになりそうですうん
どうぞまあ結構いっぱいあると思うんですよなんかちょっと自由
もうちょっとっ
男と ii も深いですねうんうんっ
エネルギーさしかに目に見えないです
なるほどなんかそうですね音実は僕が最初に興味を持ったのも
音なんです
以上ライディングがさん
えっこれが僕が映像にきっかけを
興味を持ったきっかけてもらってが高校生の頃ぐらいです
が音楽好きだったのでいろんな音楽を聴いてて
その中であのミュージックビデオであります
いろんな格好いい c 人とか実写であったりとか
僕もそういうのに憧れて将来ちょっとこういう格好いい
民需首を作れる人になりたいな
で高校の時に決意しますそういう子は映像に入れたいんだろうと
大学そういう大学があるんですねでそこに行って
結局大学院まで行って6年間
映像の
基礎から制作するのまで大学で学ぶことになります
今日はその6年間の集大成と言いますか
a
終了大学に修了制作です
を
これ本当にひとり見せたことはあんまりないんですけどちょっと恥を忍んで持ってき
ました
ちょっとご覧ください
モーションピンターという
これあの10年前も僕がこれを釣っています
コレなにしてるかというとこれパフォーマンス北結局やってるんですけど
6年間映像馬なんですけど結局行き着いたのはパフォーマンスアートをやっていると
これ何をやっているかと言うと実は裏で音楽が流れているんです
ねぇライブペインティングってありますよねあの音楽を聴いて即興でその印象を絵を
書いていくとそれの映像がはこれやりたいと当時僕を持って作ったものです
この時やっぱり越冬まあきっかけはミュージックビデオで映像に興味を持っても結果
そのパフォーマンスになったこの大学の6年間のブックはその映像っていう手法よりも
なくその
音をビジュアル化するっていう方に興味がやっぱり言ったっていうのを発見したんです
で
一応映像もちゃんと学んでいたので映像の
会社に入って晴れてディレクターに下積みを経てですけど
なることになります
これってその大学の時は
を通し書くか一緒なんですけど
この仕事をし始めてから音だけではいけなくなるんですね色んなクライアントさんから
色々なオーダーがあって
でその中で僕が見つけたテーマというのは
これです
以上 alive the emotion
感情を視覚化するということをやりやろうとまぁ
思いましたでその重巡年間で行ってきた
これどういうことかというと例えば車売りたいんです
この車は乗ったらすごいワクワクするんですよ
まなこハンドリングとかよかったりとか
早いとか
それって言葉で言ってもなかなか伝わらないんです
の僕はその映像化すると言うじゃあライズっていう武器を持っているので
それを一目で見る見たら分かるぐらいに映像で表現することかい
それというのはつまり映像で僕は人とコミュニケーションができるっていうことに
気づいて
で
逆にその映像を作っていてコミュニケーションできない映像というのは駄目だろうと米
僕がその仕事をしていく中では人とちゃんとコミュニケーションできる映像を作ろう
なんかそういうふうに考えて仕事をしていますコミュニケーションというのは奥から
一方的にあのやるものじゃなくて
ああああああ
互いにするものだと思うんです
なので見ている側の国が伝える喜びがあるんですけどそれを感じだった時に見ている側
の人も1喜びがあるはず
例えばこう映像を見ててあーこれいい映像なとか思う時ってたぶんそういう武田と
保管思う
で金がこうお仕事してて一つ出会いがありました
金箱ちんさんって誰です
彼はがっ型インターフェイス経理旧車
という聞きなれない方が気を持ってきてもらう人なんですけどあれ何をしているかと
言うと
楽器で人とつながるそういうインターフェースを研究している人
具体的に言うとですね
花粉という打楽器があって
な楽器なのでタイプなんですけど
普通太鼓ってま楽器全般そうなんですけどあの
耳が聞こえないとあのまぁ楽しめないですよ
彼はその耳が聞こえない人でも楽しめるガッキー
そういうひとつでもコミュニケーションを取れる楽器を作ってる人です
具体的に言うとその
しその音を振動に変えて相手に伝えようっ
楽器を作ってみるとです
彼がその楽器を作っている中で振動だけだとちょっとどう
物足りないとっで
これをビジュアルで表現したらどうでしょうというか
表現してもらいたいという連絡がありました
音の視覚化です
で映像を使ったコミュニケーションなのでこれはもう口やれますと
いうふうに二つ返事で ok します
でもう1人
彼は吉田氏やさん
これはうちの会社のプログラムをしてくれる人ですけど
エンターテインメントエンジニアという方は下を彼は自分でつけています
どういうことかというとえっと2あのう
ちゃんと技術者でありながらちゃんとその鑑賞者の熱戦を持って
どういう体験をデザインするか常に新しい体験は取材していきたい
そういう
お気を持った人です
この3人でそのか品誰とでもコミュニケーションできるか方も作る動きになり
それがね
それがかも3つあるんですけどさ耐性
なら彼が叩くとき6周動画を買ったりということです
ハーフ叩くとコインプリコレ音霊くれての場合無理です
元を決し犬みたいな魂みたいなまま4個です
ています
の同時に叩くと二人行10型太線月になります
タイミングが合うとこれが3人同時に見ると三角形ができます
こんな感じで良い
弓だけじゃんって
メアそして新郎もあるん
800でもん
なども
海が聞こえない人でもできるって言う餓鬼がこれでできました
この作品でやってたのはその単に音
ビジュアライズするっていうだけではやっぱり足りなかったんですねどうしてもその後
やっぱりセッションしている関係性みたいなどうも見えて
ただポンって叩いてパンと出ただけだとえば面白くなくなっちゃうんですね
てそこであの
考えたのグルーヴを可視化しようということを考えてこれをつくって
どういうことなのかというさっきの線で繋がるアイディアとか
相手と心が通い合った瞬間みたいにはビジュアルで見えるとそれでなんかその
セッションをしている
雰囲気をビジュアルで感じてもらいたい
そういうことをしましたこれを実際いろんなところに返事したんですけど
さあ何が起こったかというと
これ何もあの
復興取扱説明書階ですこうやって遊んでくださいねみたいなとか
ある展示があるんですけど
これ一切何も置かずにただ楽曲思うときっ
そしたら
取材発生的にた改定
あっても一緒に叩くとは線がつながるねみたいな
そしたら
自然に行こう3人でセッション水しかあっあれはすごいなあと思って見ていたら
アンモニアの子供のお母さんってますけど
子供がどっかアティエ長の中央 day パケこれあー自然発生的に
そのぶーセッションが行われて子どもが参加して踊っている
なんかちょっとすごいなって
僕も今までただ単に映像視覚化とかその音を視覚化って
できてるつもりだったんですけど全然そのすごさに気づいてなかったというか
これで何かそのもっとすごいことができるんじゃないかと思うようになりました
これをさらにスプラッシャーフィッシュ
これはなんかパッ
もので助けまで会後3つで固定でやってたんですけど
やっぱり子供のはっきりのあるので走り回るようにしたい
あと3人だけとなっていますブルー new もどってね
ライニング一気になったでしょ
篠笛
ここの頃は何もピッタリだって何でもいいです1回センサーをいろんな楽器床につける
ことでこんな感じ
滑る
でもちろん肌の主郭からなくてブルー防止カップ
視覚化したいです線つながる
ねこれつながったら絶海オトダマくんがあっている
to do れパーデュー sfc し
これもたぶん誰トレーに水が声ですけども
彼らだが4日昼から本来なりました
これ品何回も言ってますけど言葉を使わずにコミュニケーションできる
ツールなので
言葉は使わないということは言語のバリアがないということです
つまりその
世界中どんな人とでもこれこれあればその場でコミュニケーションをとることができる
その証拠に超高齢と言えば今までいろんなところで得て展示してきたんですけど中には
中国とか
まーまれーアジアところでもっ
店長をしていますその時僕を言ったんですけど
現地の子供と遊ぶんですけどほとんど日本でやってるの
本当に変わらないようなコミュニケーションが現地の人同士もみんなと同じような感じ
でやっ
だかほんとあの
言語を超えたなという感じがしました
で a
あとですねもう一つ
た世代間交流というのは
今
話題になっているらしく
福祉施設でこの展示をさせていただくことは結構最近増えていてそこで問題になって
いるのがその
今その
高齢者の方は高齢さ受けのそういう施設に入られたっ
でこの前幼稚園とか同じ世代で集まっちゃっ
家に帰っても中ちゃんと住んでませんとかで
世界を雅恵また l コミュニケーションというのがなかなか出来てなくて
やっぱりそういう豊かなコミュニケーションがもっとあるべきなんじゃないかっていう
のは
叫ばれているんですよ
そこで問題になっているのがまあその一緒に住んでないとかもあるんですけどやっぱり
その
高齢者のところに子供が入ってもなかなかコミュニケーションをとるツールがない
お話しするといってもその何を話したらいい
そういうのがあって
でそういうところにこういうツールがあるとその場で言葉の関節に
コミュニケーションとれるねすごく可能性を感じてますっていうのを言われています
もう一つこれはユダにもなるんですけど
ボカやこの
人間ところに人間だけじゃなくてもいいんじゃないかと
これ動物とコミュニケーション取ろうと思って取れるんじゃないかと思ってまして
でもちろんその動物は言葉をしゃべれない
これもしょうがないんです
でもあの図形とか色は認識できる
でにも本当にその
イルカを使って
図形で
コミュニケーション等の研究を実際にやっていてけっこうこれはその大学の先生と一緒
にやってるんですけど割といけるんじゃないかという感じです
see
なので将来ちょっといるかとしゃべれるかもしれない
ん
ちょっとワクワクします
はいっ
で最後にもう一つだけ
この展示をやっていて
子供がまぁ元が走り回る
疲れ果てるぐらいまでも狂ったように木幹ずっと走れ待ってるんですけどそれを見てて
ちょっと気づいたのが
この動き自体を
可視化してあげるとちょっと面白いんじゃないか
と思っ
動いを使っています
これですモーション動きの可視化
これはちょっと行ってみようか
本当のビーズです
ni
リアルな部分も普通の
入って
で来ればおこう
動きもある人このこれはペラセンサーがつい
動いた軌跡がその奇跡の畑地王子さあキャラクターに公平化し
直線になったらゆずみたいにができてぐるっとまーすとなく団子虫みたいな化できる
その可決に本当に自分の歩き方によって形が変わる
それだけだとその aa ケーションっていうかやりたくなくなっちゃうね
空いてる口を踏むとこれがチップ機レイプ
この中してと飛躍人の動くと
鑑賞できるような仕組みてい
糞なら切れるんですけどなんか寄り添うとの合体時だと
なんかそういう
つぼみのんこれでなんでしょね
恐れもなくて楽器でもなっ
自分に動いた動き自体でいいです
コミュニケーションを取れるようにますナンパやっぱ面白いよ
この被曝に動いたからしかしこうごう
そういう体を伝ったコミュニケーションができる感じたか
a とっ
いかがでしょうか
あの
可視化や米みたいになってもらえたかダーク
もらえたでしょうか
見えないものをハッシュ化するっていうのは何が面白いのかといったら結局なところは
その
新しいコミュニケーションが生まれるということだんですね
あの話すとかだけじゃなくてなんかその
今までなかった全然違うコミュニケーションが生まれるということがやっぱり面白いん
じゃないかと
見えないものを可視化するってこの考えて見えないもそこらじゅうに転がっているので
さっきあの紙とか
エネルギーとか
そういうなんかそれがこうみえたらどうなるんだろうみたいなそういうのを考えるだけ
でもちょっと視点が広がるというか
生活が豊かになるんじゃないかだ
もしこういうのを
あしかしたら某面白いんじゃないというのがあったら教えてもらえると幸い
ありがとうございました
[拍手]